this knowledge indigenous ways of
thinking you have to go to the land
it's the land that's the source of
indigenous knowledge don't listen to me
you need to listen i can take you though
i know who some of these people are
and i can take you there bring a gift
you know and
spend some time with them i think we
should
be sending our brightest students to do
clerkships with
indigenous medicine people say
manitoulin island
where they can go and spend two years
learn the language learn the traditions
talk about law
still work with various communities and
their issues and
how they have to deal with the common
law because it's these
these people would then they would be
evolving they would be growing up on
indigenous ways of thinking
about the world that where they've gone
to the source
of this knowledge
[Music]
hello plastic pills listeners this is
victor brazoni joined by
matt mcmanus today we're joined by dale
turner
dale turner is an associate professor of
political science at the university of
toronto
previously he was an associate professor
of politics and native american studies
at dartmouth college
his work focuses on indigenous politics
contemporary indigenous intellectual
culture contemporary political theory
and the philosophy of ludwig
wittgenstein his 2006 book
this is not a peace pipe towards a
critical indigenous philosophy argues
for the need to have
academically trained indigenous
philosophers act as word warriors or as
a bridge between
western and indigenous ways of thinking
something he argues
is important for indigenous issues
and justice this emphasis on language
and translation informs much of
professor turner's recent work today
matt and i had the pleasure of reading
professor turner's work in pro
progress on the politics of indigenous
translation
listening to indigenous peoples in and
on their own terms
set to appear in the rutledge handbook
of critical indigenous studies
in the paper turner argues for the
usefulness of
the wickensteinian approach to language
analysis to assist with
the translation of indigenous ways of
thinking and western ways of thinking
for example he argues that to understand
indigenous spirituality
vickens wickenstein's concept of
language games and family resemblances
can be a useful tool both for western
institutions but also for indigenous
people themselves to translate their
concepts in a way that
minimizes misunderstanding and conflict
dale turner welcome to the show thank
you i'm
so grateful for the invitation and uh
glad to finally be here yeah for sure we
tried a couple times obviously and
finally we got a time to work out um so
maybe we could start
with you know how did you come to
wittgenstein
um as being a central figure for you to
deal with these kinds of questions
yeah that's a good that's a good
question um
i might so i start i started off
um as an engineer and um
i was in the navy and didn't handle the
seas too well
um but what got me into philosophy
was our court case our my community so
my father's uh tamiya
nishnabe from tomogame ontario
uh in northern ontario and
uh our community had a case that went to
the supreme court
of canada ultimately in the bear island
decision which is
a bit of a i think it's a disastrous
uh decision more so at the superior
court of
ontario um but basically what we tried
to do is to argue that we had not we had
not signed
the the robinson huron treaty of 1850
and
one of the things that we had to show
was um we had to go into a court and
show that we had
sort of a indigenous connection to the
land in other words we had to go
into a court and prove that we were
indigenous
um we provided uh an explanation for
that
we we brought in our medicine people we
brought in anthropologists and
so on and but the court basically
basically said
that we didn't really uh constitute
indigenous peoples that we um
that we basically too many of us spoke
english
we were christians um
and uh so that
got me interested in uh
because i actually thought the argument
was pretty simple
right we had 13 traditional families
that been there for
a long time in particular we have a
dodem system that was in place
we had a way of connecting uh
people and our language and land it was
a kind of uh
i mean i was not raised as a
traditionalist but these values
were kind of deeply embedded in my
upbringing in the way that i
certainly understood my place uh on the
lake on the homelands called the
documentary
so i got interested in in that and my
cousin at this
at sandra larone gave me
uh i think she probably gave it to me
because it was the shortest philosophy
book which was the second discourse
you know on the rights of any quality i
think it's like 40 pages or something
and she probably thought i could handle
it
russo yeah yeah um and and it's it's
interesting to
i think for someone i think i think what
i realized was that
i kind of was more of a philosopher type
of thinker even as an engineer um
but i got really interested in this book
because
it very clearly puts indigenous peoples
in the state of nature well close
depending on how you read yourself but
close to the state of nature
but it's measured right against against
the western european cultures as civil
societies
so i found that really interesting
because this this logic was
was part of it seemed to flow out of the
the
the rational rationale in the supreme
court decision
right that that we're being judged from
the by from the outside from a western
european perspective
not from within the way we understood
ourselves
so right from the beginning by question
and it's only now i've really come back
to to embrace this more i think in a
philosophical context which is how do we
how do we listen and understand to
indigenous peoples in and on their own
terms
and i think that i got interested and
that
that was the kind of driving question
for me to study philosophy
to and i decided to to do another
undergrad
and philosophy and then i was uh there's
an interesting story about
how i ended up at mcgill but i do have
if i have time i have a short
little story about wittgenstein because
so in the navy i was at um i remember
doing some studies at the
technical university of nova scotia tons
it's called
and i used to hang around in the stacks
and uh
you know the bees right in in the
library and
i would pull books off and i would read
them and didn't really understand some
of them caught my eye but
i picked off i picked out a book and
i took it out of the library because it
was so interesting and
but i tried to read it i think i got
four pages into it
couldn't do it took it back you know but
there was something that appealed to me
years later when i went back to study
philosophy
i was in the third year seminar uh with
uh sheila mason and at concordia
who's an awesome professor and i
realized
that the investigations which is what we
were reading was that book that i took
off the show
so there's in some way it was appealed
to me
intuitively uh and of course you know
it's
it's a it's one of the weirdest texts uh
to read
if you you you you really can't read a
prima facie are you just getting no
pick it up and you know i i tried
reading it to my kids to go to sleep
and actually that worked quite well now
they think about it
but anyway uh so there was this
connection with
language and and and trying to listen
and understand
uh what i do what i don't think i
appreciated at least initially
um and really it's not until like i kind
of fred for
his remarks on fraser's golden mouth was
how do how can we understand or
appreciate maybe that's the better word
that people think about the world in a
fundamentally different way
everything's put on all life forms like
life worlds
are put on in conversation with each
other that
the differences are are are so
deep that to unpack them is not going to
come out
in in a template or an argument and i
think that's what
led me to wittenstein but i think having
the right professors
exposed me to that in in somebody like
sheila mason
um it was was really key
uh for that great that that's a that's a
super interesting story um
yeah i like how you just thought you
happened to pick up that book as if and
then it ended up being the
meant to be it was meant to be it was
meant to be yeah
um and actually that that you know i'm
just going to say when i was interviewed
at um
miguel um charles taylor sitting next to
me came in you know with his t-shirt
that's kind of intimidating
i said sitting out with his eyebrows for
um one just wonderful um
wonderful man and tully and
uh we sat down and they were talking
they said
oh uh it says here you you've
studied engineering and and you're
interested in wittgenstein
and uh taylor leans over to me he says
we expect the same quality of results
yeah yeah because vickinstein he started
off as an engineer is that right yeah
yeah i mean he has he had a patent on a
jet engine
all right jpl is based on on his
design of a of a jet engine really
did you know that yeah i remember
bertrand russell said that
he was surprised when this young man
came in uh to cambridge right because
he had just an undergraduate degree in
philosophy and he would always show up
at his office
and just start badgering him with
questions and apparently at first
russell was
kind of like the way you would be you
know you want to be a bit encouraging
but you know at the same time it's like
you know
you know who i am right i got a lot of
things too and then gradually realize
like oh this guy's a genius
in fact you know uh he's actually making
me question everything
uh i know of about philosophy and then
apparently i think it was like two years
later he was like
why can't i convince me there was just
no point in anything that i was doing
right
you know and i was thinking i was
talking to myself that's gotta be pretty
humbling if you're a world famous
philosopher like russell
and an undergraduate just convinces you
that your entire career path
is you know punk right well i mean
there's
there's uh michael ignatieff uh tells
this story about
uh wittgenstein showing up at the i
don't know which one it was the moral
sciences club
in cambridge you know showing up for
isaiah berlin who was giving a talk
on and i think the topic was are there
moral propositions
uh the way native tells the story though
is kind of like
that wittgenstein comes in listens you
know with his entourage behind him sits
down
listens to him and then and then of
course his hand goes up and
within like you know 15 minutes totally
destroys
this argument to the point where berlin
turns to political philosophy after that
never writes another philosophy you know
that's just that's funny
you got to love these these uh old
stories that dickenshine is just like
the perfect philosopher for those yeah
i did think he thought said something
funny though which was um
because i always thought this was true
when i read him that he was by far his
worst critic
you know what i mean every time you read
his book he can just see in the back of
his mind he's like yeah not good enough
you know check it out so let me um also
kind of give the listeners a sort of
bird's eye because it's actually the
first time we've talked about
wittgenstein on the podcast we talked
about a lot of other philosophers and
theorists
and i think it's worth sort of
mentioning and you lay it out quite
nicely in your paper
um the sort of two stages of
wittgenstein right so he starts off as
kind of
trying to understand language in its
logical form right and he he has that
famous quote
um which is you know where of one cannot
um
what was it i'm trying to actually find
it do you do you remember it offhand
where if one cannot speak thereof one
must be silent be silent exactly
exactly right so it's like but then i
think he becomes
uh that so that was the tractatus
logical philosophicus and then
um later on uh what was collected as the
philosophical investigations written
in a very in a quite different style
right in the form of aphorisms
um he kind of does this whimsical
engagement where he's having a dialogue
and i think in your paper too you
describe it as he's having a sort of
dialogue with himself right a back and
forth questioning
and i think underlying the the
discussion he has with himself is he
sort of realizes that
trying to understand language um as like
sort of a logical
structure doesn't make sense because
there's
and and the key concept i think is forms
of life
um and of course there's much more to
that but i don't know i wonder if you
could talk about that that sort of that
transition from a lot from
his trying to encompass everything
logically to this more
uh sort of like embodied lived form of
language
i just wanted to make one interjection
though and say uh just as a matter of
hope to
all the aspiring including herself i
remember reading uh
an edition of the philosophical
investigations where britain's
wickenstein that included a preface
witness and written for it
and he said something the effect of all
i tried to do was write a good book
and i haven't even achieved that so
basically apologizes to whoever's
reading this uh
so you know to anyone whoever sits there
thinking that uh you know they're a
little insecure about their work and
this is a problem
just remember that one of the towering
figures of european philosophy in the
20th century
uh was also as you put it uh professor
turner his own worst critic
right yeah yeah i mean it's it's true in
fact well and and in fact he didn't
publish it did he
somebody you know it was published for
him after he died
uh but i do think the first part now
they call it sort of the first part i
think it's the first
633 um
you know um aphorisms as you call them
or remarks
uh i think he had those in place
that's why a lot of purists will read
that part of the investigations
because it's what he had settled in his
mind um
one of the things he used to do is he
would write them right
uh these these these uh remarks
and little cards and he would arrange
them on the floor and he would
you know he was never he was never happy
with the way
that i think um he he would
certainly make transitions from one
topic to another always rearranging
uh his his work but i i think there is
something to
maybe it's the youth or the arrogance of
youth you know that and you're 22 or
you're young and you're you know uh
because i actually think he's
used to go around of course he of course
he wrote the tractatus while he was a
prisoner of
war right italy and and
uh that's gotta help you get
make a deadline um
i'm not getting it he uh
he's a bit of a fatalist too i think he
in fact i think he got
a medal you know for bravery because he
just thought
if i'm gonna go i'm gonna go you know
kind of thing so he went for it
but um i think the the idea that he
had solved right the major problems of
philosophy which is
what we can say we can say clearly and
what everything else we have to pass
over is nonsense right
right there's a kind of a very nuanced
view of
of what nonsense is of course the vienna
circle
picked that you know up with the
principle of verification to take it in
their own direction
but i think there's still this kind of
element of mysticism
right in the tractatus of of um
what later becomes i think not knowing
how you apply the rule right
in the application of the rule itself
how do we know
to move on sort of thing when we grasp a
rule
and that's why i think rule following is
so so difficult
uh in in the investigation so i think
there's more recent more recent
scholarship and i'm not a victim scholar
by any means
but i think there is a lot more unity
between the earlier and later periods
and i think part of that is uh
hit the willingness that he had as a
younger man
to kind of say this is the answer and i
think what he's
done in the investigations is he's given
up that
uh um he's he well it's a difficult
thing right
to pull out of wittgenstein that um when
you talked about the
the preface you know i wish i'd written
a i wish i had written a good book but
it hasn't happened oh well here it is
anyway
but i think the other part that comes
with this is i
i i give you my thoughts these you know
what
in whatever lane form they're in but i
hope they
make you think for yourself and i think
there's really something to that
in the in the later work which is
he is somebody who has put the effort in
to think through some very difficult
problems that i think
most philosophers would realize are
difficult problems
they may not be happy with the ways done
because
let's face it a lot of uh certainly in
analytic or positivist tradition
they're gonna say he gave up right he
just he basically gave up and said
look there really is no answer there are
the infinite number of language games
and
the the meaning is to use so the use
because depends on your
practices that you engage in and you
know and i just
i just don't think that's quite right
about wittgenstein
um so but i do think
uh what ultimately the shift is in the
earlier work to the later work is
how our attitudes
our attitudes about thinking and our
attitudes about how we
recognize others and what other people
say and how they use their language
becomes
central to his philosophy it's a form
well i guess what we would call
pragmatism pragmatic view
ordinary language was certainly what you
know
some philosophers took over um from
his work i don't think he would
categorize
his work that way but i do there's
something about
um that what he's trying to do
with language is show us something
and that showing is it's an exceedingly
difficult thing
to do it's a form of aesthetic or poetry
but at the same time it's concerned with
arguments and
you know and so you know trying to
bridge i'm glad he's put that work in
um i figured he took 16 years
of you know um driving himself
insane practically you know
uh pacing behind bertrand russell and
one in the morning and
you know bertrand russell saying are you
thinking about logic or your sins ludwig
was this answer answer both
that actually brings me to um well i
want to say my own interpretation of
this very quickly and then actually i
had a follow-up question for you that
kind of brings us back to indigenous
politics
and the relation of some of this to that
uh so my own kind of
take on this uh is that both of these
books uh because i agree with you 100
that there's a strong unity between them
uh in fact i say almost an
overwhelming unity because the
personality of the man is just so
forceful
right it's that he's trying to cure us
of our desire
to engage in the traditional project of
european philosophy
right uh namely this quest for certainty
i think that what really shifts between
the two books is
how he goes about it because the first
book i think as you put it
very poetically says in the introduction
that look this is just like a ladder
right
uh once you use it you can throw it away
and you have no more need for it any
longer because the tractatus kind of
shows you that
once you say what can be said with
certainty it doesn't amount to
very much that's of interest right uh
you can now describe the world
as a set of atomic facts uh sorry
propositions about atomic facts
uh but you know nothing about aesthetics
and morality and spirituality which is
all the stuff that we really want
right and then i think you said you know
in the philosophical investigations he
says
even this quest for certainty about
things like
uh atomic facts is just pointless right
you know language is too complicated
no need to do this so we still reach the
same conclusion that this quest for
certainty is misguided
uh but we can't even have certainty
about the kind of things i thought we
could before
that's just my take on it no that's i
think that seems exactly right
yeah but like my interest in indigenous
politics relates back to oh sorry not my
interest in just my interest in your
take on individual politics uh is this
kind of totally asked
question because i think it's really
interesting that you said you read
rousseau first
and this provoked you because one of the
things that some people like about
rousseau is precisely that he's
in the second discourse inequality is
slightly critical of modernity and
european civilization
and almost seems to fetishize uh some
kind of
uh primitivism right uh as he sees it
right now in the state of nature we were
happy we had genuine community
exactly yeah this myth of the noble
savage that emerges right
um and then you know on the other hand
you have people that like what tully
criticizes a lot
uh somebody like john locke right who'll
say all the world is america the people
there
aren't really using the land very well
uh so we have no reason that we
shouldn't go in and take the land from
them and
put it to good use this extremely
xenophobic view but
scholars are very critical of both these
perspectives i think justifiably now
one right you know on the one hand to
kind of fetishize uh
the so-called noble savage and then the
other hand to just denigrate their
cultural accomplishments because it
doesn't coincide with our vision
precisely because it does kind of map
the logic that you're talking about
uh very clearly in both instances right
we only see this person from
our perspective right what it means to
us and i'm just wondering how you think
wickensteinian philosophy
can help us as a tool you know uh to
kind of overcome
this othering process uh politically
and i say that also because not a lot of
people think of wittenstein and think oh
politics
immediately certainly i didn't right i
think what
uh i like about a wittgensteinian
approach is when you encounter otherness
your immediate response and reaction to
it
is um is in a sense uh as
a form of openness
and um and that openness
it has to do excuse me that openness has
to do with
with your attitude about your everyday
sort of the way that you
are more willing to listen to people you
know who these people are
right they're you know elder type of
people who uh
are uh whose disposition
is one of of listening
right and they uh so and i think
wittgenstein's approach to language
creates
a good way to understand
language and to understand
that others also use language in a
different way
and you may use the same terms but
you're going to come at
things from different perspectives by
necessity
which which means that at the end of the
day
it's uh and i really like this about
vacant shine is
at the end of the day it's what we
shouldn't be looking for is the fact
that we can
all understand each other that's the
goal
but what's more interesting about that
is we can at the end of the day is
most of us can understand each other but
there's always going to be someone
who doesn't and they're participating in
the conversation
in the same spirit that we are and in
other words there's
always this there's always this need
for future dialogue to revisit our
language to revisit the context and how
we use our language
and i think that's that's the lesson
that i get
from a wittgensteinian um approach so if
you set aside
the fact that you're you you're not
doing this because you want to
understand
the rules or grammar um
but the fact that grammar and rules
exist it's
it's it's a different i think it's a
fundamentally different approach to
uh to meaning and and then a kind of
normative language that comes out of
out of meaning yeah i was gonna say i
sometimes heard it described as you know
an open texture to language right we
don't settle on a final vocabulary
you know in this daridian sense and say
you know this is how we speak about the
world
and morality and everything properly and
anyone who doesn't we just don't have to
listen to them you know they're getting
it wrong
we say well you know kind of one of the
nice things about human language is
the huge variety of games that people
play with their words
right it's a testament i think really to
the creativity of the human spirit
generally and
particular communities in particular but
uh especially uh but i i want to know uh
can you give us an example
uh of where this kind of theory or this
approach i should say you know kind of
caches itself out
in our approach to paul the politics of
difference uh just for
our listeners who might find this a
little bit abstract what
[Laughter]
oh on the ground
sure two things come to mind well i
think the first one is the treaty
relationship the contemporary
treaty relationship in indigenous
politics
and where this where this first comes
out is in the royal commission's
um royal commissions on aboriginal
people sorry final report
tully was a a big so i worked at the
royal commission
in in my in year between after my year
one and year
year two i took the second year off my
phd to work at the royal commission for
the two co-directors
of research um um
martin castellano and david hawkes and
so i got to spend a year i lived in
ottawa and
wow what a great job my job actually i
got an office
my job was to to
summarize all of the incoming research
which literally was cutting edge anyone
and anyone who worked on indigenous
issues worked for the commission
you know and to keep track of this
research that was coming in
and then summarize it for the the
commissioners and for uh for the
co-directors so
i learned a lot i would literally come
in put a pile of papers on my desk put
my feet up and read papers
to this day i'm still waiting for that
kind of lifestyle
but but one of the things that the
commission did
i think was in their approach in their
what we would call vision
was uh that we needed to renew the
relationship
we needed we need to renew the legal
political relationship
in a way that um and
a way that respects the early treaty
relationship
where in a short period and
didn't last for a long time but there
was a time
sort of around the fur trade early fur
trade where
the the relationship was such that both
sides benefited
right for example in early quebec the
the europeans could not go into quebec
right they had to meet them at the
at their fur trading so they weren't
allowed so there was that meeting place
right where they
respected each other they benefited from
the trade relationship and so on
the four principles that came out of
that were mutual
recognition reciprocity and
responsibility
and sharing and these four what they
were called
principles the commission called them
principles but they're really kind of
practices
that were in place in the early
historical relationship
where they listened to the other side
right and they would meet in a treaty
relationship in that was dictated by
say the hud michonne in the two-row
wampum which is a
wampum belt that is used in treaty
negotiations the approach
their approach was we would meet we
would meet in a circle we would
we would there were protocols about for
forest diplomacy as it's called about
who could speak and what order and so on
and everybody participated in that kind
of
a process and then agreements would be
reached
but then people would go back to their
communities
with what had been discussed and they
would take it
to their own communities hash them out
they would come back again and they
would say look uh we're okay with this
but not with this
or and that process goes on that's an
iterative
process and that's the so it's the
nature
of that relationship itself that
embodies
right this treaty approach so when we
hear something like the dish with one
spoon
as a kind of wampum belt and a treaty
that's the way the hood and ashoni
understand that that the this goes
this has a long history before the
arrival of europeans
and and and where we would what
what mattered to us individually as
communities but also
for the well-being of the of the overall
relationship
needed to be constantly revisited and
renewed
and everything was up for negotiation
and
and and they had people had the groups
had the freedom to bring that in to
the into the dialogue so in a
contemporary relationship and when you
look at
the four or let's say three um
i was gonna throw the anishinaabe nation
in there but when you look at what's
going on with the wet solitain
when you look at what's going on in 1492
lambach lane
and you look what's going on with the
nega ma the indigenous groups
are falling they are digging their heels
in
to say what is important here is the
relationship that we established
hundreds of years ago that the canadian
state is still
obligated to recognize and that's that
early treaty relationship the dish with
one spoon
look we do it in our our land
acknowledgements right
maybe that's something else to come back
to in other words it's research
these kinds of practices have resurfaced
in indigenous politics
but what's happened though is the
canadian state
is coming into contemporary negotiations
in the case of the migamo and they're
referring to peace and friendship
treaties that go back to the 18th
century
they're bringing in the fisheries act
right
in in 1492 land back lane they're
bringing in the indian act
they're saying look the chiefs already
signed off on this the wetsuoton
the hereditary chiefs yeah well you may
be the source of moral authority but the
but the
the political authority lies in
the the s the indian act system
indian band which we have imposed on you
and now we're going to use that as the
as a way of gaining the consent of the
entire community
so there is this resistance
to accepting that these
age-old treaties that are
even within the common law right
the royal proclamation affirms them 1867
constitution affirms them
1982 section 35 right the existing
aboriginal
and treaty rights of the aboriginal
peoples are hereby recognized
and affirmed once again it recognizes
these
older treaties and it's supposed to
weave them into contemporary law
now we have bill c 15 which is the
undrip
the declaration on the rights of
indigenous people same thing recognize
indigenous
spiritual relationships as the source
right
of their political legitimacy and
authenticity
and then you have article 46 which says
nothing in this
nothing in this declaration can
undermine the integrity of the state
right that's that fallback that the
state has that's why bill c-15
unless it has some richer accounts of
accountability built into it is is
really as they say
aspirational so i think
where wittgenstein can come back into
this
is that we have the language of the
common law and the language of
contemporary
public policy which uses
and interprets the meaning of section 35
in a particular way
and that way without bringing up i guess
examples but that way is premised on two
assumptions one is the primacy of moral
individualism
right that that what lies at the heart
of a liberal view of justice
is the individual the individual as the
ultimate
placeholder right for m of moral value
of moral worth
and the second one is this the the
sacred claim of state sovereignty
right that nation-state sovereignty
embodies the highest
form of political sovereignty and any
other recognition
of nationhood indigenous rights
the inherent right of self-government
needs to fall under that right so
um so wittgenstein i think is a way for
for to bring those assumptions up in the
course of a dialogue
right as he says one of the important
things about an ongoing dialogue
is that we assemble reminders
right so and now what it is it's
indigenous
peoples themselves who i've become
educated in the common law john
burroughs
right as a professor mishnah bay
professor this guy's brilliant he under
you know you're not going to put one
past him on on interpreting section 35
and he understands right that sort of
colonial grip
right that this language has but at the
same time we're trying to find
ways of loosening that grip and we're
doing it through the course of our
politics
i think of which our younger people are
one they're less patient about
you know these their polemics is they've
ramped up their polemics in ways that
i think is um is is empowering in some
ways
but on the other hand you have this
older
us did i say us older folks older people
who are saying whoa you know
we we we have to be in a sense
we have to be careful about the language
right words or deeds
the language that we use in this legal
political relationship because
what are we putting at stake in our own
ways of thinking
and that's why i think that there's this
politics of translation now
most dalgovic decision as you know that
i think has taken a hold of indigenous
politics so
this treaty relationship then and how
it's being
uh interpreted both within sort of a
legal political realm
but within indigenous studies and
political theory
right that indigenous politics for
example
is um becoming a subfield in political
science not at u of t but
it i think it could we're headed there
um
so that's a way right of bringing those
voices in in a serious way that
and i think where the overlap is is in
this shared
middle ground if you want to call it
that or normative language around
rights nationhood uh this the word
inherent
right is one that i can't you know
really i can't
gra grasp that in the shift from
certainly english to indigenous
languages
did that help yeah i think i think that
definitely helped um i was
so i mean you brought up a lot there and
one of the things i think that's
interesting about wittgenstein is sort
of
the way the emphasis on forms of life to
me it sort of harkens almost like in
like an embodied knowledge like um
because it's not you can't really
cognitively i think at least on my
interpretation of vikkan although
admittedly the person professor i
learned wittgenstein from was a
phenomenologist so she wanted to play up
the kind of embodied aspect
of this idea of forms of life and i
think one of the things
um that i think is sort of interesting
when we're talking about sort of
translating and finding this
sort of like middle ground or common
ground is i wonder how important do you
see like the kind of
the place of being in the same space as
the people right so having somebody from
you know like the state the canadian
state or or for american listeners
you know um whatever the u.s federal
government like going
because to me i think you know
wittgenstein i think you even
you have a great quote in your paper
where you say he's you're quoting
wittgenstein
and he's talking about like the truth or
falsity of words and he's like so you're
saying human agreement decides the truth
and falsity
of words basically and then he says he
responds to himself because uh he writes
in this dialogue right
it is what human beings say that is true
and false and they agree
in the language they use that is not
agreement in opinions but in forms of
life
which is kind of like i i always read it
as
a kind of seeing how a word is used in a
context of our
reciprocal social relationship and
really have to kind of be there
embedded to to really get it you know
what i mean it's kind of like when you
move to a different country and
i was kind of talking about this with my
girlfriend because she studies
ethnography a lot and you know
ethnography is all about going in
and i just wonder how important do you
think it is like can this
this translation be properly done
without
more of that actually going and being in
the space to really see what that form
of life is
to use wittgenstein's language yeah oh
that's also a really good
a really good question i you know it's
almost like
um you know in in contemporary
indigenous politics
law and politics that section 35
has run its course i think i i
i don't think indigenous peoples are on
board
with or i don't think they're hopeful
that section 35 as a you know
constitution
part of the canadian constitution is
able to
reconcile uh indigenous ways of thinking
about the world
within the existing you know language of
the common law
and um and i think what
what indigenous activists and and
leaders are pushing for is
not a particular interpretation of
indigenous rights or even nationhood for
that matter
but they're making room for indigenous
law
indigenous law itself is a third order
of law in canada
and that is in some ways the source
of i think the only word i could use is
it is authenticity i suppose
and that's an uncomfortable word however
i think that
what that does is in someone in a
practical way because indigenous laws
is um you can go to uvic now and you can
do
a law degree in and ditch in indigenous
law and so it's
starting to find its way and it's
certainly part of indigenous studies
so where so where do i how do i how do i
think about sort of translation
yeah without the embodied or if it's
possible i think that
embodiment is a term is an is one of the
so so the term that i would use would be
um in an indigenous way uh
so would be an indigenous
portal concept in other words they're
in they're bringing in certain turns
best example of this is actually in in
new zealand
where uh tino ragatira tenga is a
concept that roughly means chieftainship
it was
you know it's a fascinating fascinating
uh the watangi uh treaty of otegi signed
in 1840
has an english version and a maori
version the maori version
was actually recite i was recited orally
to the chiefs in order to get them to
sign
the oral ver the the baudi version was
written
by a missionary and the english version
was written of course
from from the sort of policy people on
the
on the british side so you have the
semantic nightmare
booyah base of uh you know different
interpretations and
understandings but let me let me come
back to where where am i heading with
this
i think i think though the in some ways
um that the it isn't
it isn't the arguments that we're after
as i said it's changing people's ways of
thinking
and ways of of living that is key
so here's here's one example of how i
think this could work
um so you know in law the really the
brightest
the best and the brightest when they
graduate
apply for these clerkships right with
judges it's the most prestigious thing
you can get is a
clerkship with a supreme court justice
and
i think we should have in our law
schools
once we have indigenous law sort of as
part of the part of the curriculum
which is happening but i i think for
indigenous knowledge indigenous ways of
thinking you
have to go to the land it's the land
that's the source
of indigenous knowledge don't listen to
me you need to listen
i can take you though i know who some of
these people are and i can take you
there bring a gift
you know and spend some time with him i
think
we should be sending our brightest
students to do clerkships with
indigenous medicine people say
manitoulin island
where they can go and spend two years
learn the language learn the traditions
talk about law
still work with various communities and
their issues and
how they have to deal with the common
law because it's these
these people would then they would be
uh evolving they would be growing up on
indigenous ways of thinking about the
world that
where they've gone to the source of this
knowledge
and i think that that creates within
people a kind of existential
what do you want to call it a sort of
existential shift from this
phenomenological
but i would even call it embodied new
embodied knowledge or like new
inter-subjective embodied knowledge or
something like that
yes and i think there's so i think that
that
what you do is you it's the people that
you
you want to trust certain people to
be able to do what's right in terms
of being able to listen to the other
side and there are these people out
there jim tully is one
you know melissa williams is another one
there are these
non-indigenous people and and then on
the other side as well there's sort of
john burroughs who
you know and but we're not quite we're
not quite there yet because it's
individuals who are plucking out here
and there
and i think what the kinds of changes
need to
filter through to the everyday
everydayness of canadian society and
that's
that's just huge and i don't know if
that's a pipe dream or
uh you know it just raises a host of
other issues
whether or not that is possible or
desirable for that matter sorry yeah
well i was going to matt did you want to
ask something yeah i know i just want to
make a comment and then i had a
pretty open-ended question to invite
dialogue let's say
um so i think that there is definitely a
kind of
uh cheesy interpretation of the light
wick and stein uh
that kind of cast itself out as what we
now call ordinary language philosophy
uh that does tend to relegate individual
experience to
comparative unimportance right uh you
know and you see this sometimes in
wickenstein's expressions that look
philosophers of hitherto always
suspected that there's some deep
significance to
what we say that goes beyond the words
that we use
and that our job is to figure this out
and he says you know that's not true
right everything is open to view uh
because there's nothing more than just
the words that we use uh and
the implication of that would be well
there's nothing that you experience that
i can't know
since all you need to do is explain it
to me and if i understand your words i
get the essence
of it right or i get the gist of it as
well and i do think that kind of cheesy
with castinianism
because i don't think that's true with
the man himself who's
mind-bogglingly deep and second-guessed
everything right um but it certainly is
true of kind of ordinary language
interpretations of them so
that's kind of my comment what i was
interested in actually can i just hold
you there for one second because i think
i
i just want to say i think that the the
open of you part
is not so much that the language is open
to you but it's that our practices
are open to view so like the way that
we're using them is what's open to view
and that's how we can um come to some
shared
understanding which i think fits with
what just professor turner was saying
about
you know the the clerkship would be
useful because you'd actually
get to see what's open to you by being
there in a certain way
oh absolutely and this is where i was
getting at my second that's the
non-cheesy i guess that's the non-cheesy
vacation
i know people have held bad versions of
everything but like i'm thinking of like
um
in the 1990s there was a kind of
movement in um
right-wing political theory in canada to
kind of
just be exhausted uh by debates about
cultural inclusion
as then as there were now right i think
i think people like peter emberly
who i studied under our carlton uh when
he was kind of reflecting on the efforts
to incorporate indigenous peoples into a
new constitutional order
just saying can we not just have an end
to all these debates you know let's
settle it and move on
and i think what's really nice about the
non-cheesy view of wittenstein
folk uh victor is precisely he says look
why do you want to stop the dialogue
right
dialogue is an ongoing thing it never
ends because there's
an infinite number of language gains
that we have to play uh being embedded
in them obviously really helps
and so you should constantly be
recognizing that you're going to have to
learn from one another
right and i think that's kind of uh
both a critique of this conservative
ideal for politics right that we can
solve these problems once and all
but i think it's also a critique in a
more uplifting sense because it says
look why would you want to stop learning
from one another i mean learning always
is going to have problems associated
with it
but it's also an opportunity for you to
grow and become someone who's
more cosmopolitan i like that word in
your outlook
than you were before right do you think
that's true oh sorry
uh do you think that's true or no yes
um stop the dialogue
i'm sorry could you eat what you said
please no um
no i think that's right and and sorry i
ramble everybody
victor will tell you that i ramble a lot
oh my gosh you got to hear me going you
should talk to my students
i feel like i'm turning into grandpa
simpson that's what i think it is
you know i remember when you know
um kind of thing but um
i do i mean and i think i think this is
why i've alwa i've
i've been uncomfortable labeling myself
as a philosopher i don't
when i when i hear sort of philosophers
uh like i just i just read um
well not all of it but a lot of it some
under bouvour there's a second sex which
i'd never read before
and i think
this this woman is a genius yeah you
know like
this is such a brilliant piece of work
and and then i realized well i'm
actually the reason
one reason i think it's brilliant is
because i think she's kind of a neil
vickensteinian
really right she uses a lot she goes
from example to example to example
brilliant you know historical work and
so on and
and and then she just wraps everything
up in the last two
chapters right which i didn't realize
until i actually plowed through to the
last
two chapters but but i guess what i'm
saying is that
um i don't i don't have
a kind of theory uh a
theory of translation network here i
don't have
an account of truth um because
so so much of what i'm trying to do
is to get people to
um uh to get more people involved in
talking to each other
first of all um and then what comes of
that
is what we have to work with right so
it's it's in nurturing a kind
of conversation and the willingness
uh and to find the right people who are
willing
to see things in a way and then and and
then
i'm thinking specifically in the context
of
indigenous peoples you know because i
think there are other
women's issues right it's
also applicable for that kind of
politics as well
listening to the to the other side kind
of thing and
in the right spirit but there the other
part of this that
uh i have not sort of talked about
um is is the indigenous side of things
there are nishnavi elders that i know
and talk to and
uh and i'm i'm i'm very
uh and i need to think more about this
about well
in what way am i bringing their thoughts
into a conversation such as the one that
we're having
for example i talk about i use the word
ranga tiratenga
one reason for doing that is because not
it's not for my own in my own
community right so be mad the zealand
right which is
means something like the good life now
that's a normative term in
anishinaabeg philosophy i have to be
careful when i'm using them
even in english because i don't feel i
don't
i feel like i'm i don't know enough
about it that i'm
violating in some way the voices of
the people who i learn from so the
problem and this is where wittgenstein
in some ways uh brings in this account
of power
is useful for an account of power
because i think power is a kind of
language game itself
and is you know um is
uh and he said this once he says my
father was a businessman
um man was he a businessman uh oh
or extremely wealthy man but he said but
we need to get things done
and i think that's one of the ways that
i'm kind of thinking this through why
why bother doing this is it just because
i'm uh i'm an anti-positivist
you know it's it's because i want to get
something done which is
you crush positivism and then the world
will be right i have a t-shirt with that
i think
um but they they yeah but i think i i i
think that
there is a kind of commitment to a
particular way of understanding
something and that for take come back to
the treaty relationship
because here here is another a concept
that's important to victim which is
objects of comparison
and i think that the in the
wickensteinian approach to language
and understanding and meaning and really
and
you know tying together i think section
122 that i write in the paper is really
important which is about
getting this kind of what he calls
perspective
perspicuous representation which i
realized was
changed to surveillable representation
newer translation
and i was using the older translation
that's how old i am
but but i think that
the way that i understand what i
what i'm trying to get across is
that wittgenstein's use of language that
i've encountered i've learned about i've
heard from other people i've learned
from some
amazing people also has
a kind of objective comparison say in
huda nashoni thought
in the in the two raw wampum the two
royal wampum is a
is a uh a belt it's a wampum belt
it has two purple rose uh
and wampa belts are made of shells right
and uh
they so it has a white background two
purple rows
and they're held together by three beads
in the middle
this is called a heuristic device
since i'm going to be reading rawls in
the uh
um that there this is an indigenous
way it embodies it's and i use this word
embodiment and in an indigenous context
brings in this language of spirituality
which we haven't touched upon not my
place but but that's where it goes
but the two-row wampum represents this
this simple
you know uh metaphor of one row
represents the ships of the european
the other row represents the canoes of
the indigenous peoples and the
white background is the river that
they're traveling through together in
the same relationship
and they don't steer each other's vessel
and the three beads in the middle are
peace respect and friendship
that's what holds them together the
wampa
belt is an offering it's a gift right
and i think that's the way indigenous
philosophy and storytelling can function
but the words are gifts
and you have to be open to receiving
them and seeing them
but but you're left with you're left
alone to figure that out for yourself
and then the elders done their job kind
of thing and
uh you know let's eat kind of thing and
um
it's always nice to bring elders
chocolate that sort of thing because
because um that's a good way to to share
share
uh share a conversation or tea
but my point is is that that true royal
wampum for me and i read that early
actually shortly after rousseau
and then when i finally read
wittgenstein in this sort of richer
context
they are within their own cultures
embrace what i would say family
resemblances
or clan resemblances an indigenous way
that they're using and understanding
language in the same way and that's a
fruitful way to have a dialogue
so that's an academic context um
but it has very practical consequences
to it
you know when you're talking about the
treaty relationship so
right that no i love that answer um and
you you mentioned indigenous
spirituality and spirituality you know
you bring it up in the paper and one
thing is like that word spirituality in
english i feel like just has such
baggage with it right it's like one of
those words that just means so many
things and
can give some people like i mean even
myself i admit it kind of gives me like
a
i don't know like like a new aeg like
just like a i have like a negative
connotation with and
and i was kind of i wanted to ask you
you know how like what what
you know what's a way of understanding
uh indigenous spirituality or like
what's the
i don't know like like yeah what's
what's so what's what's like
a way that that could alleviate like the
the terrible baggage that that word has
in english
gosh i know this is a good deck yeah i i
thought you would tell me the answer
that so i would not do
he i gave a talk once in um i was a
junior
i think his first year at dartmouth you
know and um this
these people came over from belgium and
they came heard
you know i gave a talk in a conference
they came out and said you've got to
come
give a talk in belgium so i went to
belgium and then i gave this talk
on um by opening up with wittenstein
and i could see that they were kind of
visibly disappointed
you know that i wasn't wearing my
feathers and
but but you know like they didn't have
to import an indian guy from vermont
to talk about wittgenstein they you know
this uh
like how cyril i think was set to cool
but so there's there's an expectation
you know and to be able to
talk about things and i think this is
the this is the the
downside this is the downside of
indigenous uh certainly politics but
is that um there are a lot of
indigenous uh people who
purport to be able to speak about
indigenous spirituality um
and it's i think that doesn't make them
a kind of medicine person it makes them
dangerous
uh in many ways not everybody i think
once they get it so i think it comes
down to attitude and
and and sort of your approach humility
right and um you know there's
i remember uh listening to one of the
first times i listened to taylor lecture
of course a lot of people disagree with
me on this
um thinking of some people i know i hope
they're not listening
no i i'm i want people to listen so but
but there's a certain um with some
philosophers and thinkers and we all
have our favorites
there's just a humility about the way
they speak and they walk us through
their ideas and complex ideas
and i really think that there are human
beings whose thoughts
are gifts and it takes a while
to to see that back to simone de bouvoir
for as an example
so much of that book is angry right it's
it's written out of anger but it's also
a gift
it's a gift because i think at the end
of the day she's optimistic
otherwise i don't think she'd be doing
what she's doing anyway my point is that
there are people who can talk about
these issues in a way that invites
right participation and but i do think
that this term indigenous spirituality
is uh it's a it can be a dangerous term
but um come back to the land
acknowledgement
you know i think for traditionalists the
way to
the way the acknowledgement is
understood
as uh is
almost like a prayer right and it's the
word that i guess i would use
would be ontological you know
one of my colleagues in our as um ryan
decare who's mohawk a language speaker
he's a beautiful speaker
and he gives our he gives our blessings
and then
to start off our meetings you know and
uh and i i know from where the way he's
talking
i know and you know talked earlier about
you have to be there
it's definitely the case right that
there's a
there it's not just performative in a
sense that this is our obligation
but you i can i really feel that from
him don't ask me how or explain it or
whatever but
but there are these contexts that are
respectful and and you feel that sense
of respect wittgenstein himself was like
that
he was as he says i'm not a religious
man but
uh i would never make fun of a religious
worldview
and i think the one thing that he was
able to do was to point
at people who were in a sense authentic
and living according to
the way that they understood how to live
a good life and he saw that and that's
why this show say distinction is so
important
it is a date and actually i would maybe
take a quick shot at answering my own
question which is like i mean i think in
english it has like a
it has baggage because of just like
western i think or like i don't know
christian metaphysics or something like
it has a specific connotation that i
think misunderstands
or like imagine something like very i
don't know
like like has a specific ontological
feature where i think spirituality
you know could can have a broader and i
think actually so lately i've been
listening to um the audiobook of uh
sapiens i don't know if you've heard
about this famous book and he starts the
book by talking about how
like the thing that allowed human beings
to have like an agreement between
strangers right was the way the fact
that we could invent fictions that we
could all
and you know he says you know we in we
believe in like the government which
doesn't have any material
um and like the way these fictions
basically bring human beings together
and and to some extent like when i was
listening to it i was like well that's
kind of like spiritual in a way like
you could think about like the way it
works to bring human beings
um to believe in something that allows
them to work together which i think also
links to
wittgenstein's idea of forms of life i
mean i feel like forms of life the
things
there's there's a there's a way in which
it's like a practical
embodied agreement which is in language
but also in the way that the words
and the the language in a context of
understanding each other even if we're
strangers because we're in this similar
context
um i'm not sure if i if i if i properly
put all those things together but
that was some thoughts i had taking a
stab at a difficult question i
have a funny story and then uh i'd like
to actually make my ask my last question
uh because yeah i have one more too and
i have one more too if that's okay i
know where i know it's late for you over
there uh professor turner
yeah but no the negative connotation of
spirituality that i have not even really
negative because i just think this was
funny
but i was at a a party once it was late
at night and
this girl came in and i was having a
chat with her because i was single at
the time
and she described herself as really into
spirituality and she asked if she could
read my palm and i was like
yeah okay why not you know let's see
where what the future lasts
and she came up to me and she's like
that's okay but uh first off i need to
go smoke this joint uh because if i
smoke this joint then i'll be much more
connected to the spirit world and i'll
be able to read your palm better
so i said to her you know well you know
it's not my practices
you should do it and she came back and
she was all in a daze and she read my
palm and she said
you're going to let to be 87 and i'm
like oh that's nice and then she's like
uh there's going to be two great loves
in your life i'm like well
let's see how that pans out and she's
like but you have to avoid the first one
though that was a big thing because
that'll be a dark temptress uh you want
to go for the second girl who'll be the
true one
um so you know i sometimes when i think
spirituality this is what i associated
with
with but i certainly think that there's
a deeper conception of spirituality at
work
uh in many different cultural traditions
uh and
coming from a kind of catholic christian
perspective uh the way that i usually
iterate it is using that language
uh because the theologian paul tillich
has a term that i like where he says
everyone has something that they
consider to be of what he calls ultimate
concern
right and we invent many metaphorical
ways of expressing that and sometimes
we have to understand that people's
conception of what's of ultimate concern
can become vanalyzed or bastardized like
if you worship money
or vice or whatever it happens to be but
being perplexed by this question and
feeling humble as you put it in front of
it
is actually a universal human activity
and indeed it helps you get a good sense
of the priorities that you should have
in life
and that's the attitude i've tried to
take
in recent years like you said victor by
moving myself away from those kind of
cheesy connotations of spirituality
but the last question i had for you is
when it comes to
forming a kind of dialogical relation uh
between
european civilization uh as kind of
atomic individualism
uh and the indigenous peoples of canada
what do you think could theoretically
bring us together what practices
uh do we share uh that where there's
sufficient commonality
uh where people might be able to start
recognizing a bit of themselves
in the other uh which i always see is
kind of a necessary step
uh a dialogue first off becoming
fruitful but also engaging for the
people who are
dialoguing together and actually can i i
want to fold in my question because my
question is a similar version of that so
i'll just fold it in and then you can
answer
them together at the same time and i
think that's you know one thing that i
i like i find um
you know optimistic in your work is sort
of the way that wittgenstein does lead
us to this kind of well it's possible
to to understand each other and i and
you know in contrast to and obviously
as someone who doesn't know uh
indigenous political theory very well
but i'm familiar enough and i think that
there's a trend and this isn't even
necessarily an indigenous
politics only but also even in like some
tradition like critical theory
traditions
um where there's more of an emphasis on
radical alterity right that like we
can't
understand each other right and i think
maybe you and i even talked or mentioned
glenn coulthard right like that that
sometimes it seems like there's
the more um there's a pessimism
and i earlier when matt was talking
about the the conservative
um thinkers as being like kind of giving
up like why can't we just let go that
sometimes it seems like on the other
side there's also like a spirit of
giving up for but for different reasons
because we have so little in common
that like we should give up for that so
that i think that that's like my last
sort of question is your thoughts about
that and just in general like being
optimistic or being pessimistic in the
face of very difficult political
problems and
uh struggles for and how guess i don't
know if you can put that all into one
question but
sorry well i think humor let's uh let's
start right there i think uh nishnabe
people
in particular we're funny people you
know and
uh i remember uh mike mitchell who's a
pretty tough guy
uh mohawk guy he's mohawk i probably
pound me out
for getting that wrong i'm sorry if i'm
buying five more one
tough guy man lacrosse player and you
know and um
chief war chief you know and
talking about some of these issues can
and they're hard they're hard to talk
about
when you're talking about colonialism in
the government and this happened then
this happened and
so on and uh i remember at the end
he said uh he got up and he told a joke
i
wish i could remember the joke but he
just he got up and said you know what
we gotta laugh people and he told this
joke and it was kind of a dirty joke and
and everybody everybody laughed so
i think i think humor is important
because
in a way it kind of it it shows that
we're all in the same boat in some way
right that we
that we're trying to make we're trying
to figure things out
you know and um so i think humor
is is uh is very important but
i i think at a more uh philosophical
level um i think the my example of the
clerkships
is uh is is uh is a way
a good way it's it's a sort of practical
on the ground
bringing people together another way
is in teaching um we our pedagogy needs
to change
you know and i think
for example we should
and the way we raise our children um
needs to change
in terms of uh they're a lot smarter
than we think they are
and for uh and the way i think the hook
between certainly indigenous ways of
knowing and
western european ways of knowing is in
our relationships to land and and
an environmental ethos that indigenous
peoples bring
both to academia and into into
mainstream canadian society and children
respond to that and they're and they
want
they they want to be told the truth
and um and i think that indigenous
medicine people in particular um are
able to talk the truth to power
so to speak i in ways that
doesn't make people uneasy i mean i used
to joke
you know my class at dartmouth with uh
you know privileged sort of students and
say
the first thing i said once was uh your
grandfather's
killed my grandfathers
we're going to talk about that this you
know that sort of thing
so there's open a class cold without it
that's right yeah
i'm gonna pull the book and go well i'm
all done here
but i think um i think there's something
about the way that we relate
to the to the world right and then and
then
call it environmental ethos indigenous
knowledge
there's there's one thing i'm convinced
about is that
sort of their that traditional
relationships to land
are about attitude but they're also
about knowledge
things that they know that are
astonishing
you know that we think uh so this divide
between science scientific thinking
and indigenous thinking is a false sort
of dichotomy i think
um an indigenous i think by listening to
indigenous peoples and i think what
we're just what we're
uh going through now i think is there
are
indigenous intellectuals
who are aware of this problem of
translation and are aware of
how we speak about our ways of thinking
is really important
you know um and there are people like
alan corbier who's
who's a nishnabe historian at york
university
raised on this language in the
traditions and trusted by his community
this guy's a professor you know in
history
so you do have uh you know i talked
about word warriors
in my book but now i'm talking now i'm
thinking more about medicine people
these people are bringing words that
heal
words that heal all of us and and i
think
there's a sense of urgency about us
that we need to listen to these people
and i think we can facilitate that
uh that's that it's it's we have our
people our wise people and these wise
people
matter at this time in the history and
there are even prophecies for that
in anishinaabe culture about the
importance of these people so
i think i think it's practice right it's
about practice
i think that's a good way to uh to
nurture
that ongoing dialogue and to have a
genuine exchange in
ways of thinking and that affects our
own ways of thinking
that's great um yeah i really like that
sentiment i mean the
the hope and continued dialogue and i
also love the point you made about
humor because i think one of the
frustrations i have with just you know
these days radical politics in general
you know not just on the indigenous
issue is i feel like there's quite a bit
of solemnity and
and and you know not much uh not much
humor
i feel oh i always say it right you know
um i think of myself as like a
a radical aggressive right and liberal
socialist and all that stuff and
the number one reason a lot of my
students don't like to get involved in
these issues and i talk about them is
they're like
yeah but all you people are such a drag
you know what i mean i'm gonna go it's
kind of like you're saying about a door
no before we get in this and you know
i'm not going to be able to watch you
know my tv shows without
feeling bad about myself and humor is
really important antidote to that i
think
yeah yeah well wickenshine once said
i and i said this at a it was a a
conference for a telly
uh and in montreal and um they had all
of his people were close
it was 30 40 people there and um
you know he said uh i so started my talk
and i said well
um dickenstein once said that i can
imagine it will work a philosophy that
can
consisting entirely of jokes
settle in you know um but then that's it
i couldn't pull it off
but i'd love to be able to do that
sometime yeah that would be
that would be great but on that note uh
professor turner thanks so much for
coming on i really really appreciate it
if you're curious about his work
um look out for his book this is not a
peace pipe towards a critical indigenous
philosophy and uh
watch out for the rutledge handbook of
critical indigenous studies which will
feature the paper that
we kind of talked about uh but um in any
case i'm not sure when that's expected
to come out
um professor turner soon okay awesome so
yeah
watch out for that listeners and uh
thanks
thank you thanks for having me
[Music]
you